let's go next to our caller from the 404
area code who's calling today from 4:04
hi this is a Simon from the Davenport
Iowa area hey Simon what's going on
today
hi so a big fan of this show I've been
watching for two years now thank you so
you may find this interesting
so tulsi gabbard has some signs up in
the area and you know I feel like she
what she is doing the most she can with
like the money that she has left you
know what I mean like I feel like she's
she's like doing like a last push like
their place in like a certain way where
it's like you might think that you know
they're just placed in that you know
what I mean I have no idea what you're
talking about so Tulsi has signs and the
signs are good or the signs are not good
or what were you the signs are desperate
sign of different desperation they do
yeah that's what I'm trying to say that
they seem like they're signs of
desperation and so that's the first
thing the second thing is that was a
little weird it was the second thing is
yeah okay so I've been looking at your
commentaries on Bernie's chances of
passing Medicare okay and I feel like
you're missing a factor and that factor
being that in the event we have a
president Sanders he is saying that he's
going to rally the people together
towards the
medicare-for-all and maybe get out in
the street I feel like that's really
what's gonna be the [ __ ] thing that
tips it over the edge in the end so what
are your thoughts on that I feel like
you're missing that factor I'm not
missing it I am just aware of the
reality that in the United States there
is a long history of throwing just
enough of a bone to the people to
prevent the serious type of protest mass
rallies in urban centers strategic
absences from work in order to [ __ ]
industry there's a history in the United
States of the establishment and the
corporate powers that be doing just
enough to prevent that from happening
and keeping people keeping workers in a
precarious enough state so that they
lack the wherewithal and resources to do
that because they make the calculus of
well they threw me a bone and I can't
really afford to do that so instead I'm
just gonna go to work I completely
appreciate the idea of Bernie Sanders if
elected saying listen everybody this is
an emergency we need to pass Medicare
for all right now I think that it is
just a miscalculation to imagine that
Bernie doing that is actually going to
generate the type of activism that will
get medicare-for-all passed given the
degree to which the corporate powers
that be in the Republican Party and
insurance companies will activate
against it I'm not dismissing the power
of activism I'm not do I I just am less
idealistic than some others and people
can disagree with me and that's totally
fine but I just don't see that as likely
I would love to be proven wrong you know
to be clear I'm not saying I would be
against that I think it would be great
to actually see a president say hey
everybody we've got to do this thing the
thing is called Medicare for all and
here's what you need to do that would be
lovely I just don't think it's going to
happen my prediction may be wrong and I
would love to be wrong it's not that I'm
missing it I just don't have the same
interpretation as you of you as you do
of the likelihood that that will we'll
get it get it done okay David thank you
very much
yeah have a good day all right you too
thank you so much